[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
ft's whitehall editor sebastian payne
and the political editor for wales
online ruth masalsky they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages
the metro pictures an afghan mother
handing her young daughter to taliban
soldiers hoping she might be saved by
being put on a flight out of the country
the telegraph leads with u.s president
joe biden insisting that other countries
critical of his decision to pull
american troops from afghanistan do have
the option of leaving theirs in place
the guardian hears the foreign secretary
dominic raab allegedly refused to take
calls about the crisis in afghanistan
while he was on holiday
the times says three of britain's most
senior civil servants whose departments
are responsible for the uk's evacuation
program in afghanistan are on holiday
the daily star quotes manchester united
legend dennis law who's vowing to tackle
dementia after revealing his diagnosis
the mirror carries a pledge from the
timely ill father of stuart lubbock who
was found dead in tv presenter michael
barrymore's swimming pool to continue
seeking justice for his son
the financial times says carmaker toyota
is planning to cut production by 40
percent amid a resurgence of covid19
fueling fears about the global economic
recovery
and we're joined tonight by sebastian
payne and ruth mazalski thank you both
very much for joining us this evening
good evening to you and let's start
sebastian with the telegraph and this is
joe biden hitting back at britain and
giving a pretty different version of
events to that that we've heard from the
prime minister yesterday in the house of
commons but also from the secretary
general of nato that nato forces
couldn't go it alone he says that they
can
so this is a rather curious turn of
development in the afghanistan story
particularly with regards to uk eu
relations that uh boris johnson his
government have made it very clear they
did not want to withdraw from
afghanistan and as we report in the ft
tomorrow there were many conversations
had about continuing uk troop presence
about continuing diplomatic president
presence but ultimately johnson decided
that with the us pulling out there was
not much they could do
this interview given by joe biden which
was on good morning america was not
actually broadcast but the telegraph
have got their hands on some of the
quotes actually says that joe biden said
that you know he met with all the nato
allies they all agreed that we could
leave and he also said that look one
thing i promise you in private nato
allies are not quiet they also said that
they could have stated they wanted to
and they didn't now that's a very
different spin on things because
everything we've heard um over the last
week has been the uk saying this is all
america's fault they're the reason we
had to withdraw so quickly we would have
done things very differently ourselves
and you saw a lot of that in the house
of commons on wednesday when mps were
attacking joe biden saying this is again
all america's fault now i'm sure
there'll be another round of tit for tat
for this but the key foreign policy
element of this is the uk is very
reliant on america and i think
realistically the people i've spoken to
in whitehall and in the defense
establishment they don't think there was
a realistic way the uk could have had a
serious presence in kabul without
america because for one thing the
airport is being secured by thousands of
american troops when they go who's going
to secure the airport that would need a
major commitment from other nato members
the kind of which is just really
unrealistic so it will be interesting to
see how these comments are responded to
because they just don't tally with
anything we've heard from the other
leaders yeah and ruth given what we
heard in the house of commons yesterday
given what joe biden has said what does
this tell us about the state of the
special relationship
it throws it open doesn't it because
we've had you know i think a lot of
people were obviously believed it was
joe biden rather than donald trump and
but there was there's been conversation
that this is just continuation of
trump's policy and from this side of the
atlantic and one of your um commentators
earlier if you're saying that they can
completely understand that and they're
very um upset and concerned that that's
the way that it's being seen and but you
you can't really deny that it it it is
um was very clear to his election
campaign this is what he wanted to do he
stuck to that there's some rumors now he
might keep a large number of troops um
in afghanistan for longer if his
situation content continues but you know
that very challenges probably sat there
tonight seeing these comments and then
asking some you know some serious
questions of that suppose a special
relationship although we were told
during the uh summit over the summer
that's a team that they no longer wish
to use quite so openly
no indeed let's turn to the guardian now
sebastian
increasing pressure on dominic raab uh
insisted today he wasn't going to resign
what's the guardian's take on this
so this is a report that came out in the
daily mail yesterday that said that uh
dominic rob the foreign secretary was
advised by his officials to make a call
to his equivalent in then afghanistan
government and rob was away and didn't
make that call allegedly and it was um
given to his junior minister lord zach
goldsmith and in response to that his
equivalent in afghanistan didn't want to
take the call of seeing it was someone
too junior and the foreign office hasn't
disputed that this happened they've said
that mr raab was always engaged and was
very much following what was going on
and but there's a lot of around going at
the moment about the fact that he was on
holiday and his report in other papers
that he was on holiday pay all of last
week including some details in the
telegraph about exactly how much time he
allegedly spent on a beach while meaning
and purporting to be fully in touch on
this um
labor the smp the liberal democrats
they've all called on mr robert to
resign i don't get the sense that he
will because i think fundamentally that
you know boyce johnson was also briefly
on holiday um for one day and it's just
a sense that the whole government let
the ball drop on this not just the
foreign office and not just the foreign
secretary but mr rob has been under fire
all of today he said he's not resigning
downing street says the prime minister
still has full confidence in him so i
imagine it's not going to fundamentally
affect things now but when we do come to
that government reshuffle which has been
in the planning for weeks and months
we'll be interesting to see if mr rob
does keep his job at that particular
point
yeah and
we have heard repeatedly ruth this week
haven't we that that government
ministers are entitled to take a holiday
during at recess everybody needs to take
a holiday but the former uk ambassador
to the us look kim darrick was speaking
earlier today and he said that it's very
rare for officials
to recommend ministers make calls while
on holiday and that the foreign
secretary should have recognised this
and he he should have done it and
what does this tell us
about him and and how difficult is it
for him
i think i think so far it felt a little
bit this morning like there was more
calls that rob may go that seems to be
going away now and i think really need
to look at boris thompson's um record
with his cabinet you know pretty tell
didn't lose her job robert generate
didn't lose his job um he's not in the
habit of sacking his members of his
cabinet and i think there's a really
telling line here in this guardian piece
um which is that raab's team had told
civil servants quote there was an
incredibly high bar to get him to look
at anything while on holiday and well
yeah you're right everyone deserves a
holiday everyone needs a holiday and i'm
sure that's not um you know particularly
for cabinet ministers especially after
last year you do wonder what that
incredibly high bar is that if he didn't
he didn't think that this call was what
you know met that text
and
the fact that his his equivalent didn't
take the call at such a crucial time you
know
we all work in companies we can all
imagine that boss being on holiday and
what do you do but it's such a different
um such a different game in politics
isn't it and this is there are thousands
and thousands of people's lives on the
line here and that labor line i think
yesterday from the comments from kirsten
about surely you could have um picked up
the phone i'd go you know i'd get off a
sunlander effectively to make that phone
call he's going to ring true with lots
of people and you won't need to look at
any of the horrific pictures on the
front by neither papers tomorrow to
think well surely he could have
made that call
yeah and in terms of those phone calls
as well we saw the images of the prime
minister boris johnson on the phone to
president biden but even that telephone
call sebastian took
quite some time given the seriousness of
the situation
that is true although and people in the
uk government can obviously point out
that boris johnson got the first call
after joe biden became president he got
the first call um after the fall of
kabul and joe biden obviously has
himself shown his personal investment
within the so-called special
relationship when he made his visit to
the uk he saw the queen and has
acknowledged the importance for that as
the uk is the central ally to the us
there and i think the the fact is joe
biden has really got himself into a very
hard-line position on this that he's
been a long-term supporter of
withdrawing all troops from afghanistan
not just over the past week but going
back to when he was vice president under
barack obama and it's been a lot of
reporting out of america that really
speaks to the fact that nothing could
have persuaded him so i think you know
there's obviously been some distance
there between boris johnson and
president biden and there will be some
awkwardness but ultimately the uk u.s
relationship it's about values it's
about intelligence sharing it's about a
worldview it always goes beyond
individuals and i think you can barely
name a single uk prime minister who's
not falling out with the u.s president
so that's just another one of these
particular moments but there is no doubt
things are pretty awkward between london
and washington dc right now yeah and
let's turn to the times now uh ruth and
um not just boris johnson joe biden and
dominic raab on holiday uh britain's
most senior civil servants in key
departments also away
as this situation uh grew more and more
serious
yes the times is reported and tomorrow
that philip barton matthew rycroft and
david williams who were permanent
secretaries at the foreign office home
secretary of defense are also all on
leave um it's it's a natural follow
isn't it to the dominant real question
which is is it just the minister is it
the civil servants and the senior
political um senior civil sense behind
him
um it's
it's the same discussion we're just
having is that obviously they're
entitled to being away it's um are they
you know and biden first and criticism
for being at camp david at the beginning
of this
you know the natural come back would be
they're still doing their jobs they're
still doing what they need to do but
you're contrasting the image of these
people on holiday um
with the images of the um the staff in
afghanistan who are working in the
conditions that none of us can even
imagine to try and get people out um you
know dominic webb's five-star resort in
crete looks very different you know
couldn't look any more different could
it to those horrific images of the
airports and and people in the cities um
it's it's an eternally tricky one but i
think it gives lay but it's given labor
uh
as the opposition a really really easy
win here and it's a it's a line that's
resonating with people i think which is
you know it may not make a difference in
terms of dominic rob keeping his job and
obviously these civil servants um but it
it is a line that is getting through to
people and people are thinking this is
you know it's is it another example of
one rule for them and another for the
rest of us well well the dominican rab
story was spoken by uh the mail today
we've just got in uh tomorrow's front
page with a follow-up to that story bad
call minister is the headline there
and the male's story today is that the
foreign office had said that that call
to save translators lives had been
delegated to a junior minister zach
goldsmith as we were discussing uh seb
now they have admitted no one made the
call at all
yeah and i think what you're seeing here
is not just the position of mr ra but a
systemic failure across whitehall here
the fact that you've got the permanent
secretaries of all the important
ministries involved in the afghanistan
operation being away and yes you've got
deputies and yes you have a holiday
voter system like any other job but the
fact is this is one of the biggest
moments in british foreign policy in the
past couple of years everybody knew this
day was coming and the intelligence said
that there was a real risk of the
taliban taking over afghanistan very
quickly now not as quickly as it turned
out to actually happen but the fact that
he would go away and then still be away
in the case of um
philip barton who's the permanent
secretary of the foreign office that
just seems unacceptable and with the
foreign secretary away as well you
clearly have got a power vacuum so it's
no surprise at all that court didn't
take place because there's not authority
from the top and that's a very crucial
thing within whitehall whether it's the
secretary of state or the permanent
secretary to get things done to get
things push you you've got to have that
leadership and fundamentally that just
hasn't happened so i think as well as
the intelligence failings about why we
didn't spot the taliban moving so
quickly through afghanistan there should
be a real look at whitehall here and
saying why were these ministers allowed
to go away why didn't the call happen
why did these permanent secretaries go
away in the case of some of them why are
they still on holiday while this
disaster is continuing you know we are
evacuating british personnel and there's
a hopeful that is going smoother than it
has been over the past 24 hours or so
but we don't know how long the taliban
are going to cooperate with allied
troops and we don't know when america is
going to pull out because that comes
back to what we were saying earlier when
america goes we have to go too this
whole thing could get more disastrous
and more chaotic and still is there grip
in the center of government on this
that's the question that i think boyce
johnson and dominic rob need to answer
tonight and ruth um just briefly let's
bring in the metro because i suppose
this illustrates incredibly powerfully
why this all matters why the speed of
those decisions why the urgency of
getting out people out matters so much
with the image of a desperate mother
handing her tiny daughter over to
soldiers in kabul in the hope that they
will get her daughter out
yeah it's a company it's a desperate
emotion i'm sure no no one can look at
it let alone a parent and just you know
well up basically as i did earlier when
i saw it and but i think the other
telling thing is that each paper and
each national paper has a different
picture which is mainly children
and and they're all in this position you
know this this isn't one horrific or one
journalist who's got this one photo
journalist who's got this one particular
isolated incident there are so many kids
involved in this and your footage from
your reporter at the season is is tiny
babies right through to you know um to
older kids and it's just it's the human
element you know we can argue about
biden and johnson and rob and ministers
on leave you know and civil servants
will leave
but this is the reality of it there's
these you know can you imagine being
that mother and having to to do that in
the hope that your kid's going to
survive it's just it's heartbreaking
yeah absolutely devastating and some
very harrowing images as you described
um said ruth stay with us we're going to
take a short break but coming up we're
discussing booster jabs for covid they
could be on the way in the autumn we'll
have more on that in the next couple of
minutes
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me sebastian payne
and ruth mazzowski we are going to look
inside the metro uh now uh sebastian for
a story about the autumn booster jabs
now we heard from the u.s about their
plans last night sergeant javid has been
talking about this today are they going
to happen or not
they are they are going to start next
month as initially planned because
there's been some reports over the past
couple of days that actually they might
not happen in the uk after all with them
saying the um the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization would
examine were they needed what
immunization levels were like within the
uk but then mr javid came out today and
said yes they are going to go ahead they
are going to happen the thing that i'm
most interested in is who's going to get
what vaccine because i've heard from
some people in whitehall that if you've
got the astrazeneca jab and for your
first and second shot then your booster
might be a fizer so there may end up
being some mix and matching between the
mrna and the different kinds of vaccines
to give optimum protection because we
know the delta variant has me has
definitely hit the efficacy rates of
vaccines so that is going to be quite
important we still don't know who and
what's going to get them but you'd have
to think it's going to be all over 50s
they're going to do them as soon as
possible before the flu season hits so
if it avoids another lockdown then i
think it's jolly good thing
uh yeah indeed we'll have to wait for
more information on that the initial
plan was wasn't it that they would be
rolled out alongside the flu
vaccinations we'll see
whether or not that happens in time ruth
a story on the front of the telegraph
does the welsh language exclude
minorities what's this all about so this
is a report that was commissioned by two
um organizations in wales that's art
council wales and i'm gave the
montgomery which is the national museum
of wales
and and it's it was a report commission
by themselves to look to look within and
while the telegraph has gone for a line
here that um
the that welsh means white and it means
that um the the organizations are
systematically racist because
their uh requirements exclude people who
don't speak welsh and when we reported
the story today um the way the the line
we took was where it was was different
and that was that that the same report
has found that they've come both
organizations have consistently failed
to address endemic racism and within
their um organizations in terms of
disputing funds and and that really
serious action is is needed and this you
know the report says that neither are
going to be trusted by ethnic minorities
until there's a radical change within
them which is quite damaging to very
very big organizations here in wales
okay ruth and sebastian thanks both very
much indeed